now that we have seen the formula for
permutations and combinations let's see
how we can apply them we will see two
basic cases first when we have to select
3 out of 5 distinct objects remember 5
distinct objects and second arrange 3
out of 5 distinct objects let's
understand the Select case first
selecting 3 out of 5 distinct objects
for the 3 objects that we have to select
we make 3 slots the first slot can be
filled in 5 ways any one of the five
digits can be selected after one is
selected four remain to be chosen from
the second number can be picked in four
different ways
and as to are already picked three
remain from which we can pick the third
one three ways but as we have been asked
to select the order does not matter here
and as the order does not matter we
divide this by three factorial so 60
over three factorial is the number of
ways in which we can select three
objects from five different ones we have
seen this logical approach in the
previous sessions don't worry and be
patient we will come to the formula
shortly there was another approach we
had used to solve such problems let's
say we number the five objects as 1 2 3
4 & 5 from these five objects we have to
select 3 we can select any three objects
and put them in the S category and as
the other two are not selected we put
them in the NS category there are 5
factorial ways in which we can arrange 5
different objects as three of them are
in one category we divide this by 3
factorial and as the remaining two are
in another category we're divided by 2
factorial this will give us the same
answer as this one now we come to the
formula as we just have to select the
question of arrangement does not arise
it is a case of combination we can
use the NCR formula selecting our things
from n different objects as we are
selecting 3 out of 5 this will be 5 c3
the formula for combinations is n
factorial over R factorial times n minus
R factorial here n factorial will be 5
factorial R factorial will be 3
factorial and n minus R factorial will
be 5 minus 3 factorial this will also
give us the same answer here we simply
use the formula we knew in the other two
methods we use some logic to get to the
answer of course if you remember the
formula you would get to the answer
quicker but understanding the earlier
methods would help you in two ways first
if you forget the formula you would be
able to apply these concepts and second
modifying the question slightly wouldn't
stump you so make sure you understand
the concept and then you would
definitely know when to apply the
formula and remember the golden rule
don't memorize in the next part of the
session we will see the number of ways
in which we can arrange 3 out of 5